well let's get some reaction to what
we've just heard from Gina Miller we're
joined from assets by the former cabinet
minister and Boris Johnson supporter
Priti Patel very good morning to you mr.
Patel I just wonder one I wonder what
you thought of that which you've just
heard we obviously we heard from Sir
John major earlier in the week that he
was considering legal action no Gina
Millar suggesting that if Boris Johnson
doesn't rule out suspending Parliament
were going to court again sure well look
I'm not at all surprised because this
seems to be this absolutely relentless
movement to delay brexit stop brexit
from happening and of course question
the integrity of a government a future
government now not the current
government under Theresa May but a
future government and it's you renewed
determination to exit the European Union
and do something that are selected
politicians like myself had said that we
want to do which is to deliver brexit
but if it's testing the legality as
indeed was the case with the article 50
case that went all the way to the
Supreme Court well let's not forget you
know Gina Miller was proved right if
it's about proving or disproving the
legality of her ruling in these
circumstances what's the issue well look
I think first of all the issue is that
it's now down to members of parliament
and a new government to actually take
action not for third parties by going
through the courts and I think that's
exactly how it should have been
previously as well after 2016 you know
after the referendum the government was
very clear back then that brexit meant
brexit and that we were going to leave
the EU instead we had a range of third
party anti brexit organizations and
positions that were chose to go to the
court to derail basically the whole
brexit delivery and also to tie the
hands of politicians of government in
Parliament that is simply not acceptable
and quite frankly the British public are
sick to death of this they want to see a
government now with renewed conviction
get out there and do exactly what it
said it will do which is now to deliver
brexit this should not be about the
semantics of Parliament or just votes in
Parliament or pirogi in Parliament we
now have to get behind a new government
that is very clear in a future
determination now which is to get out of
the European Union come what may by
October the 31st
six to death the public might be but
I'll say again no Gino Miller was proved
right she won the case there's every
possibility that she could win this one
it would be proved by the Supreme Court
that it is not within Boris Johnson's
powers to plug in these circumstances so
once again we heard all this rhetoric
from politicians at the time of the last
case you know isn't it time for a little
bit of self respect and self regard in
the point of politicians like yourself
you said you know what going through the
court is not anti-british it's not
anti-democratic it's fulfilling your own
it's filling an opportunity that
everyone in this country has and the
courts might just agree with that again
well well I think it's quite important
to recognize that of course politicians
particularly those who are elected in
2017 were elected on a manifesto and a
mandate to deliver brexit we are the
elected representatives who have that
job to do and that's the point of a new
renewed government going forward that it
will be in the mandate of the government
a government that you know is determined
to deliver brexit and it's not something
that we subcontract out to the courts
basically now to intervene or have court
judgments tell in Parliament and elected
politicians
on what is what can be done and what
can't be done this will now mean that
there'll be new governments and I
emphasize this again you know after
three years of stalemate of protracted
nurse of absolutely going nowhere where
everybody just wanted to please each
other we have to make sure that we now
deliver brexit we leave the European
Union on October 31st come what may
because the public the elected part of
the public that vote for us vote for
people like me are done with this now
they want us to get on and do the job so
that actually we can then get on and
deliver a much bigger brighter vision
for our country and deliver on all the
issues that matter to the electorate but
if if as you and Boris Johnson who had
repeatedly said we will be coming out on
the 31st of October come walk me why was
it why was it impossible for Boris
Johnson to agree to resign if that did
not happen that was doing the TV debates
and of course various other hustings why
would he not make that commitment to
step down if he didn't do that which
he's also committed to
well quite frankly I don't think he
needs to make any commitment on that
nature whatsoever because he is
absolutely focused on making sure that
we deliver he delivers as prime minister
in a government so he's told us that
it's going to happen at the point that
the dividing line between Mr Hunt and
mr. Johnson created let's not forget by
mr. Johnson is that he has categorically
guaranteed that we will be out on the
31st of October if we're still in the
European Union on the 1st of November I
mean does Boris Johnson lose your
support of course not because he is
committed to leave in I think
everybody's missing a fundamental point
and principle here which is Boris
Johnson is absolutely unequivocal about
the fact that we want to leave we should
be leaving by October 31st this is not a
case of extension any more we can no
longer be anti-democratic and continue
to kick the can down the road you know
delay is defeat it's as simple as that
we have to leave on the 31st of October
come what may that is a law of the land
it is exactly how it's now been
established in Parliament and with the
EU and so the focus has to be on finding
the right type the right process of
right agreement in terms of how we leave
and of course it is responsible that any
future government led by Boris Johnson
concentrates on doing exactly that it
actually does the preparedness that it's
required to leave on October 31st and at
the same time in good faith engages in
proper negotiations considered
negotiations with the EU on that whole
process on leaving with an agreement as
well Boris has been very clear that he
does not want to be in this situation
when we don't have an agreement and
quite frankly it'll be the job of his
government to work day and night to
actually get on and actually deliver
that outcome so that we can leave we can
deliver brexit and we can leave on
October the 31st should trip Boris
Johnson have been more effusive in his
praise and support for us to Kim and
Eric at during that television debate we
learned this week of course that even
Boris Johnson believes that what he said
that night in part played a role in
circumcising to resign
well look i think forest has been very
clear in subsequent interviews and in
his media appearances as well about kim
Zarek and also he spoke in another
interview I think with Andrew Neal about
the background to that I mean I think
it's absolutely right Boris has spoken
in support of asakim and I think that's
the right thing I've actually worked
with the Kim Derek as well in Washington
so I just don't think it is now about
giving support quite frankly what has
happened and the focus has to be on this
whole leak inquiry and making sure the
person the individuals responsible are
held to account because quite frankly
civil servants senior ambassadors need
to have the license to operate they need
to be able to support their ministers
and work within the parameters of
government to do their job if that is
the case then why did Boris Johnson not
criticize the President of the United
States after he called our man in
Washington stupid because I think the
focus absolutely and rightly so I've
said this in the days in this week as
well the focus has to be on this leak
and who was responsible for absolutely
you know putting out this information in
the public debate its domain and also
breaking confidences and Trust basically
and the consequences of that you know
we've now seen with Sir Kim resigning he
felt he couldn't stay to continue doing
his job and at the same time of course
this has repercussions within our own
civil service and our own diplomatic
community and how much you know how
confident they feel about doing their
jobs so I think actually we should be
looking backwards we've got to look
forward but at the same time make sure
that we have the right kind of sanctions
in place for individuals who behave in
this way and leak what is sensitive
confidential government information no
one is denying that the leak inquiry
needs to proceed and if it can arrive at
conclusions as to who were responsible
all the better but it just doesn't stack
up to say on the one hand Boris Johnson
wants to support our well-supported Sir
Kim Derek wants to support civil
servants diplomats being able to do
their jobs around the world and when the
president of the United States says some
things pretty horrendous things about
our representative there silence from
Tim Johnson
well I don't think I don't think it's
the case that Boris has to give a
running commentary on everything that
the president has to say I mean that's a
fact
Boris has been a former foreign
secretary and he's worked incredibly
well with diplomats around the world and
presidents and heads of states around
the world - it is not for him to keep on
giving a running commentary he's been
very clear quite frankly in his support
of Sir Kim as have many other
politicians to her members of the
current government I think the focus
quite frankly now is on how the foreign
office can continue to do its job its
work and importantly now focus on what
happened with this information how it
got out of something like that from
happening again I'm not after running
commentary from Boris Johnson but if you
can direct me to one instance of where
you know the former foreign secretary
has been critical of Donald Trump and
appreciated well he has spoken
previously about President Trump in
terms of his comments in the past now
you know that's a matter for Boris and
of course he'd spoken about that in his
time as foreign secretary as well I just
don't think now we need to dwell on the
past we have to move forward and quite
frankly our focus right now and this
will be the focus of a new government
will be to renew our standing in the
world and that will happen through
delivering brexit but also delivering
for our country post brexit and
absolutely reestablishing our strong
ties with leaders with prime ministers
with presidents around the world and on
top of that strengthening our diplomatic
community as we prepare to leave the
European Union I suppose the issue here
is that for a lot of people who are pro
brexit this doesn't look especially like
taking back control but reclaiming
sovereignty instead swapping control for
Brussels for control from Washington
well look I disagree with that
completely because at the end of the day
the focus as I've repeatedly said has to
be that we leave the European Union and
we establish ourselves yes domestically
in Westminster as a government but also
internationally back out in the world
all over again and so there are some
great opportunities ahead and I think we
have to reflect quite frankly you know
after three years of going nowhere
internationally and domestically on
brexit it is time for a change there's a
great opportunity ahead of us it's time
for absolute renewal across our
government to messy
in internationally and that will
absolutely be the focus of Boris Johnson
you know if he becomes Prime Minister
and also when we can actually get on
with doing the tasks that we've all been
given to do and elected to do since the
2017 general election and whilst we have
you MS Patel
what job exactly do you want in a Boris
Johnson cabinet well look I'm not asking
for a job at all I want to see Boris
elected as Prime Minister I want to
ensure as I campaigned constantly to
convince the Conservative Party
membership that they should vote for him
to become leader of the Conservative
Party and Prime Minister because only
with Boris will we leave on October 31st
and and this crisis that we've had in
British politics after three years of
going nowhere and quite frankly that is
the focus that we need right now across
our country and in the Conservative
Party